Game of Thrones is so epic and sweeping
and we always say to each other we say
it would be so great if people could
experience it on a big screen having
seen it just now on IMAX it's a
completely different viewing experience
I've never seen it on a screen like that
with that kind of detail you will not
fall tonight looking at elements I just
never noticed before and I've watched
these episodes hundreds of times you
knew I didn't poison Joffrey I'm still
kind of in shock it's a completely
different viewing experience and one
that's so immersive and so superior
Kusha with these two episodes I just
think about how much is packed into the
finales this was remixed for IMAX and to
see that level of picture quality
combined with that kind of sound it
transform the experience
hearing in an IMAX put a big smile on my
face I got goosebumps
remains fingerprints are all over the
show there's a real force in muscularity
to a lot of his music which is such a
perfect fit for us if you have a 25 foot
mammoth attacking a 700-foot wall you
better have the music dick and shoulder
that image
there's an intensity and a clarity IMAX
just wraps you into the story so much
and I mean you feel it in your gut the
communal experience of being surrounded
by other people who are gasping at the
same moment it's the way it's really
meant to be seen not with two or three
or ten other people but with 400 other
people to be able just to feel like
you're there it's just something you
don't get watching it on television
the emotions and the loves and the lusts
and the hates with the power and the
immersion in the scope that you get with
IMAX to see it on such a big screen that
I feel like you can see it over and over
again and you still discovering new
things it's just a whole new way of
seeing an experience